As you can see, the receiver
itself is pretty simple.
Extend the broadcast receiver class
and override the onreceive handle
as you can see here.
Receivers are lightweight components
meant to listen for broadcasts,
react, and complete within five seconds
that usually means simply starting
a service or sending a notification.
To have your receiver start listening
for broadcasts, you need
to register it either through an entry
in your manifest like this
or dynamically within
another application component,
usually an activity like this.
Then you define the intent filter
that specifies the broadcast event
you want to receive.
You can do that either here
in the manifest,
or if you're registering your receiver
with an application component
such as an activity, you can create
your new intent filter like this.
The biggest difference
between manifest and dynamic receivers
is when they're triggered.
A programmatically-registered receiver
will only receive broadcasts
while the app is running,
while a manifest declared reciever
will start your app specifically
to receive your broadcasts.
For example, I usually code
with my noise cancelling headphones on,
so a music app app like this
might want to register a runtime reciever
to listen to the system intent broadcast
that announces when headphones
are unplugged.
That will allow it
to automatically pause playback
when your audio routing switches
from headphone to speakers.
In this case, we can use
a runtime receiver
because the app is guaranteed
to be running if music is playing.
On the other hand, if I'm using
Google Cloud Messaging
to listen for new data from my server,
I want to register a manifest receiver
that always listens
for incoming tickles
from my server and will wake up
my app if it's being terminated
to trigger the update code,
usually a sync adapter,
which is something we will discuss
later in lesson six.
There's a bunch of system broadcasts
you can monitor to help your app react
to changes in the system.
You can see the system broadcast actions
within the intent documentation
at developer.android.com.
One great use for broadcast receivers
is to monitor for changes
to internet connectivity
or charging status.
Imagine your app has to upload a movie
or calculate the next 10,000 moves
in a game of chess.
How might you use a receiver to wait
until the device is plugged in
before starting that process?
Should it be a manifest receiver
or a broadcast receiver?